[Music]
Dutchess Megan was regal in a navy-blue
Dior dress with a Stephen Jones hat the
american-born
royal had her hand on her husband's arm
as they arrived at Westminster Abbey
with William and Kate the foursome
attended the service commemorating the
100th anniversary of the royal air force
/ royal protocol Megan and Harry walked
in behind William and Kate the newlyweds
also sat in the second row while the
Queen Prince Charles and Prince William
got the front spots reserved for the
monarch and her heirs to the throne
[Music]
some royal watchers noticed that Megan
crossed her legs during the service
while Kate performed the more
traditional Duchess slant with her legs
leg crossing is not exactly a royal
no-no but many women refrain from doing
the cross in the presence of Queen
Elizabeth later the family assembled on
the buckingham palace balcony to watch
an Air Force fly over Megan had a
prominent position right next to the
Queen who spoke to her new grand
daughter-in-law during a festivities
Kate wore a sparkling brooch on her
Alexander McQueen dress she's an
official patron of the RAF while megan
has yet to receive that honor but no
balcony appearance for Prince George and
Princess Charlotte who watched it all
from a palace window later this
afternoon megan changed outfits dawn in
green chiffon she as she and Harry
touchdown in Dublin for an official
visit to Ireland tonight at an evening
reception Megan wore dress number three
for the day a sleeveless black cocktail
dress at a reception held at the British
ambassador's residence
you
[Applause]
[Music]